estelle merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors je vais me le dire
la république en marche perd la majorité
absolue
oui et de juste et samira avec l'arrivée
de ce 9e groupe mrm père en tout sept de
ses membres apparentés ce qui porte à 2
188 le nombre de députés à l'om c'est
juste en dessous du seuil de la majorité
absolue fixée à 2 189 sièges pour autant
à la création de cette nouvelle entité
ne devrait pas empêcher le gouvernement
de faire voter ses textes puisqu'il
pourra à s'appuyer sur ses alliés et
notamment ceux du modem qui compte à 46
députés alors ce nouveau gros vous
l'avez dit les baptisés écologie
démocratie et solidarité il se veut je
cite ni dans la majorité ni dans
l'opposition il est co présidée par
mathieu mathieu orphelin et paula
fortezza excellent rm député de la 2e
circonscription des français de
l'étranger figurent aussi dans ce groupe
e cédric villani ou encore delphine
batho à l'ex ministre ps de l écologie
en tout ils sont est de 17 à intégrer ce
groupe ce groupe qui a listé à quinze
premières priorités parmi lesquels un
plan de réindustrialisation une
l'égalité hommes femmes ou encore le
rétablissement d'un système de santé
robuste
merci et celle pour toutes ces
précisions